[Music]
a new report just out this morning is
shining a spotlight on sexual misconduct
in the entertainment business
a non-profit group called the hollywood
commission
surveyed more than 9 600 people in the
industry
only 35 percent say they believed it was
very or somewhat
likely that those in position of power
would be held accountable
for harassing someone who worked
underneath them the hollywood commission
is chaired by brandeis university
professor that's
anita hill she first gained national
attention back in 1991
when she testified i still remember that
day when she testified at the senate
confirmation hearings
for supreme court justice clarence
thomas was she accused of sexual
harassment he denied those allegations
anita hill joins us for an interview
that you'll see first on cbs this
morning
good morning to you anita hill really
always good to see you
we've got a lot of fantasy we got a lot
to talk about but i'm going to start
with the survey
it says most workers believe those in
positions of power
won't be held accountable for their
actions yet only 28
of the workers who say they experience
misconduct reported it
so what does that tell you well it tells
me that there's a lack of trust in
systems
and the workers will explain why they
don't report
they don't report one because they think
no one will take them seriously
they don't report because they fear
that they will be retaliated against
and they don't report because they think
that
nothing will happen to their the person
that they're accusing
has it has the times that movement made
a difference do you think
we found that the time's up movement uh
and the
uh uh measures that have been put in
place
in the last year or so have made a
difference
it's just not enough you know cultural
change is
very slow and that's what we're trying
to do it's more than just putting into
place
measures and processes and policies it
really is
moving and working inside organizations
to change a culture of silence
so what are you trying to do to bring
about real change how do you do that
well we've done a number of things and
and particularly as it relates to
accountability
uh one of the measures we're introducing
is a new platform that will allow for
greater accountability it's a tech
enabled platform
that allows for an individual
to
log on to an app that they will be
provided
by an organization with with their
associated
whether it's a studio or a guild
and they can report problems that
are occurring in their workplaces you
know the battle for equality in the
entertainment industry
sort of seems to mirror what's going on
in social justice right now as well
don't you think
absolutely the issue of accountability
is not limited to
hollywood it's not limited to issues of
of sexual harassment
the issues of accountability process
movements like black lives matter people
want
accountability for the deaths of brianna
taylor
uh and george floyd people want
accountability for
where we are right now in in with covet
and the issues that people are facing
with their help
yeah yeah i wanted to talk to i wanted
it's bigger than any one survey can
capture but we've
definitely worked hard to understand
where workers are with the issue of
accountability and what they want
in order to solve the problem i hear
that i wanted to talk now to private
citizen anita hill is she available
maybe she's wearing different glasses is
she there
should i change my glasses yeah i'd like
to yes i'd like to talk to private
citizen anita hill if you don't mind
because because she said that
you're absolutely not convinced that a
thorough supreme court confirmation can
happen
before the election why do you think
that
people are concerned about
uh so many things that are going on
but to start with just let's let's think
about what a confirmation hearing
is there for it's there for the senate
to understand the nominee and the
nominees positions and qualifications
and character it's there for the
american public to understand uh the
nominee
and what they bring to the court in
terms of their
judicial positions um
and the public really needs time to
absorb all of this especially in the
middle
of where we are right now with the uh
with so many things including the
election that has captured
everybody's imagination yeah let's talk
about where we are right now you know
joe biden was very tough on you during
those 1991 confirmation hearings
yet you have announced that you are
going to endorse him what did it take
for you to get past that
i thank you for i announced because
it really at this point i understand
that the problems of harassment whether
they're in hollywood or
in in your local restaurant are severe
uh and it's not just about harassment
you know there are
there's a whole range of gender-based
violence that people are experiencing
and again the question of accountability
comes up over
and over again we as a country need to
do something about those problems
we're working at the commission to do it
and i know that organizations throughout
this country
are working but i think it's really time
that the
the government uh really looked at this
problem as a huge public
a problem and and developed an agenda
all right anita i'm sorry we've got less
than five seconds i'm sure
joe biden was glad to hear that you are
going to endorse him thank you so much